hello
oh no
you all ready for this the new roomie
well hello there little one
oh who's that everyone it's mama she's
coming
hunkasaurus look at that
so my new roommate is uh
my mother she has decided to
come and
live on the ranch
she wanted to
come and help me on the farm and stuff
and you know give me a hand with things
and she was you know looking to sell our
houses and kind of retire and stuff but
there will be rules
[Laughter]
uh it feels good to be home
are you the muddy mess are you the muddy
mess
huh oh
hi baby mother what
let's go to the farmer's market let's go
let's go what can we have this fire give
me a hug no well you got to know how to
operate it
oh i need that little the little one
just trying to give me a fresh one my
mom's uh definitely happy to see me head
in the right direction she wants me to
be happy overall you know i mean just
like every mom wants to be you know
let's uh boogie down and go get some
something to drink
after a long week and uh doing chores
and stuff it's saturday it's beautiful
out and uh i'm feeling like a margarita
remember those
my mother i've been in seattle for less
than two weeks and a week it was it was
helping you move
are you like opposed to starting to date
although you have fully gotten a divorce
oh yeah i would like to get on my ducks
online
before i start sure another commitment
sure
i know you don't want to think that way
but
if that's what it looks like right
my mom does use that word
scammer a lot regards an alley but
um
i'm not wholeheartedly uh with that you
know parsons herself is such a kind
school christian woman well she's not
she's a scam
i just really think you should get the
ball rolling and talk to a divorce
attorney
and just get her out of your hair
i agree
[Music]
you